et je veux nous fixer un horizon
augmenter significativement
c'est à dire doubler sous dix ans la
présence des policiers et gendarmes sur
la voie publique
cet objectif nous pouvons le tenir il
faudra peut-être
créer des postes ici ou là en fonction
justement ce que les travaux qui
présideront à la loppsi permettront
d'identifier mais nous avons la
possibilité de dégager des marges de
manoeuvre par des réformes en profondeur
et des exigences
il flotte dégagé pour cela les policiers
des tâches administratives en
développant les missions des personnels
administratifs
il faut aussi réexaminer le temps de
travail pour renforcer la capacité des
unités de terrain
les cycles horaires sont devenus
illisibles
et je demande en la matière qu'un
travail de fond soit engagée en lien
avec les représentants des personnels
pour que l' équilibre de vie des agents
et la présence sur le terrain se
conjuguent mais les cycles horaires ne
correspondent plus aux besoins du
terrain à ce que vivent nos concitoyens
et même à ce pour quoi vous vous êtes
engagé
soyons clairs c'est le